c'est une entreprise qui recrute en
permanence la plateforme téléphonique
Armatis à toxiny-simbaud emploi
plusieurs centaines de conseillers
clientèle mais pour ces syndicats si
l'entreprise n'attire pas c'est parce
qu'elle paye trop peu ses salariés ils
étaient une centaine à débrayer
aujourd'hui faustineau
téléphone pendant deux heures ce matin à
toxiny des salariés du centre d'appel
Armatis Touraine ont cessé
temporairement de travailler pour faire
entendre leur mécontentement j'ai
répertorié sur le parking environ 125
salariés je dirais qu'il y a largement
les trois quarts des salariés présents
sur site qu'on débrayé aujourd'hui j'ai
pas encore les retours sur SHIFT des
salariés en télétravail qui ont débrayé
mais qui sont restés sur leur domicile
la cause de cette mobilisation des
salaires qui seraient trop bas et un
manque d'accompagnement des salariés au
vu des conditions de travail il y a
beaucoup de pression des personnes qui
qui se mettent en arrêt maladie parce
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus on a beaucoup
d'heures supplémentaires depuis le mois
d'août et encore il y en avait déjà
avant donc il y a des personnes qui
craquent et qui supportent plus si
j'étais toute seule financièrement je
sais que je m'en sortirais pas j'ai 800
euros de loyer sur un salaire à 1300 et
quelques c'est pas possible après avec
les courses etc ça fait 11 ans que je
suis dans l'entreprise et ça fait 11 ans
qu'on est à 5 euros de ticket restaurant
ce qui aujourd'hui ne suffit pas on
parle de prime d'inflation la prime
d'inflation c'est pareil on n'a pas
c'est refusé à chaque fois aujourd'hui
ce débrayage c'est c'est aujourd'hui
c'est c'est en fait ça n'appelle au
secours un appel avant tout à une hausse
des salaires au prorata de l'inflation
quelques travailleurs ont d'ailleurs
choisi de prolonger la mobilisation et
de faire grève toute la journée on ne
soit une journée de salaire prêt ça je
le conçois totalement pour les collègues
qui ne font grève que deux heures en
revanche il y aura pas d'impact
financier ils nous font mal au
portefeuille pourquoi nous on leur
ferait pas mal au portefeuille aussi la
direction n'a pas répondu à nos
sollicitations des négociations
annuelles obligatoires commenceront le
23 novembre en l'absence d'accord les
salariés pourraient reconduire le
mouvement